ADMINISTRATION DURING WATERGATE.
AND A FORMER FBI SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE ADVISER, PHIL MUDD.
JOHN, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR IN THIS
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FILING,
ESPECIALLY SINCE THEY ASKED FOR
40 PAGES INSTEAD OF THE 20 THEY
WERE GRANTED.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO SAY.
>> WELL, THEY MADE IT VERY CLEAR
IN THE MOTION TO THE COURT
REQUESTING THE ADDITIONAL SPACE
THAT THEY FELT THAT THEY HAD TO
ADDRESS THE FACTS THAT WERE NOT
PROPERLY LAID OUT IN THE TRUMP
BRIEF, AND THE LAW WAS NOT
PROPERLY LAID OUT.
AND THAT CERTAINLY IS TRUE.
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
WANTED TO GO AFTER THAT.
I THINK WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
IS PUT TOGETHER A VERY
COMPELLING KNOCKDOWN OF SOME OF
THE COOPERATION CLAIMS THAT
TRUMP HAS MADE BY LAYING OUT THE
SCENARIO AS IT UNFOLDED, AND
THEY CAN DO THAT NOW WITH WHAT
THEY COULD DO ONLY UNDER SEAL
FOR THIS SPECIAL MASTER -- I
MEAN, EXCUSE ME, FOR THE
MAGISTRATE JUDGE TO GET THE
PROBABLE CAUSE.
THEY CAN NOW DO THAT IN LAY
LANGUAGE, AND BROADLY EXPLAIN
WHY THEY HAD TO DO WHAT THEY
DID.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THEY
WANT TO DO IS KNOCK DOWN THE
IDEA THAT THERE IS AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE HERE.
THERE IS NONE UNDER THE LAW.
IT IS A FANTASY THAT TRUMP
DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU CAN'T INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AGAINST THE EXECUTIVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S TRYING TO
DO HERE.
BIDEN HAS THE FINAL WORD.
TRUMP IS NO LONGER PRESIDENT,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO STRAIGHTEN
THE LAW OUT ON THAT.
>> WHATEVER IT, IS IT WILL BE
THE MOST WE'VE HEARD FROM DOJ
SINCE THE SEARCH ITSELF.
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN RELEASED
TO THIS POINT WAS IN ADVANCE OF
THE SEARCH, THE SEARCH WARRANT,
THE AFFIDAVIT, THINGS PREPARED
BEFORE.
THIS IS A CHANCE NOW TO RESPOND
TO WHAT'S BEEN IN PUBLIC.
PHIL, THERE'S THIS GOVERNMENT
REVIEW PROCESS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW OF THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
SEIZED AT MAR-A-LAGO.
ONE BY THE FBI THAT BEGAN IN
MAY, THE OTHER BY THE OFFICE OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
WHAT DO EACH OF THESE REVIEWS
DETERMINE AND HOW COULD THEY
AFFECT THE INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK THERE'S TWO PIECES OF
THIS.
I CAN TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DETERMINING, BUT THIS IS
A POLITICAL PROCESS, NOT A
NATIONAL SECURITY OR
INTELLIGENCE PROCESS.
THE FBI IS LOOKING AT A LEGAL
CASE.
THAT CASE INVOLVES WHETHER
SOMEBODY HAD INFORMATION THAT
WAS INAPPROPRIATE TO KEEP.
THAT'S A LEGAL QUESTION,
OBVIOUSLY.
THE CIA AND THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, THE
NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY, ARE
LOOKING AT A SEPARATE QUESTION.
NOT THE LAW, BUT WHAT
INFORMATION WAS HELD AT
MAR-A-LAGO, HOW SENSITIVE WAS
THAT INFORMATION, AND HOW COSTLY
WOULD IT BE FOR THAT INFORMATION
TO BE REVEALED?
TO CUT TO THE CHASHGS I THINK
MOST OF THAT IS IRRELEVANT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WILL DO WITH THIS.
I THINK BOTH SIDES WIN.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO SAY
AFTER THE DAMAGE ASSESSMENT THAT
THE INFORMATION THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HELD WAS HUGELY
SENSITIVE AND WOULD HAVE BEEN
HUGELY COSTLY HAD IT BEEN
REVEALED.
AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
SAY THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY
OF THIS WAS EVER REVEALED.
SO THEREFORE, WHY WERE YOU IN
SUCH A RUSH TO GO TO MAR-A-LAGO?
THIS ENDS UP AS A POLITICAL
STORY.
>> SO JOHN, NOW THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS ADDED AN ATTORNEY
TO HIS LEGAL TEAM, WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT TO SEE DIFFERENT IN THEIR
LEGAL STRATEGY?
PERHAPS MORE COHERENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HE'S GOT A REPUTATION AS A GOOD
LAWYER.
HE'S WON SOME BIG CASES IN FRONT
OF THE U.S. SUPREME COURT AND
THE FLORIDA COURT.
WHAT I COULDN'T FIND IN LOOKING
AT HIS BACKGROUND, THAT HE HAD
ANY UNDERSTANDING OF NATIONAL
SECURITY LAW, AND ITS KIND OF AN
ESOTERIC BODY OF LAW.
I DON'T SEE HIM HAVING ANY WASH
BASED EXPERIENCE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
OPERATES.
SO I THINK THAT HE'S GOING TO BE
LEARNING AT FIRST, AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE UNDERSTANDS
THE CONCEPT OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHICH IS PRETTY --
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT REALLY
COMPREHENSIBLE TO MOST
NON-WASHINGTON LAWYERS AT FIRST.
THEN THEY GET IT.
SO I THINK HE'S GOT A LEARNING
CURVE, BUT I THINK HE'S A GOOD
LAWYER.
>> PHIL, I WANT TO ASK YOU
FINALLY, WE HEARD JOE BIDEN
TONIGHT SPEAKING OUT STRONGLY
AGAINST THE ATTEMPTS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE FBI, WHICH WE HAVE
ALREADY SEEN ONE THAT WAS ALMOST
DEADLY.
AND THEN THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE ABOUT THE FBI AND ON
TOP OF THAT, SENATOR GRAHAM'S
COMMENTS THAT HE THINKS THERE
WILL BE VIOLENCE IN THE STREET
IT IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT SIN
DIETED.
FIRST OFF, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
HIS COMMENTS, AND HOW DO YOU
THINK THE FBI IS REACTING BEHIND
THE SCENES?
>> LET ME HESITATE A MOMENT,
JOHN.
MY MOM IS NOT WITH US.
SHE WOULD HAVE WASHED MY MOUTH
OUT WITH SOAP.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS A GOOD GUY,
AND IN THE GREEN ROOM I'VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME WITH HIM.
BUT IN MY WORLD, LET ME CUT TO
THE CHASE.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COMMIT AN ACT
OF VIOLENCE DON'T NEED TO BE
TOLD TO COMMIT AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE.
THEY NEED TO BE TOLD THAT THEIR
ANGER IS VALIDATED AND THAT
THEIR ANGER IS APPROPRIATE.
SENATOR GRAHAM VALIDATED PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE THAT VIOLENCE
AGAINST A SYSTEM IS APPROPRIATE.
HE'S GOING TO APOLOGIZE, HE'S
GOING TO SAY THAT NOBODY EVER
TOLD ANYBODY, INCLUDING HIM, TO
COMMIT AN ACT OF VIOLENCE.
BUT I FOLLOWED EXTREMISM FOR 35
YEARS.
AN 18-YEAR-OLD, A 0-YEAR-OLD, A
30-YEAR-OLD IS GOING TO LOOK TO
HIM AND SAY HE JUST TOLD ME THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO BE ANGRY
ABOUT MAR-A-LAGO AND I WILL DO
SOMETHING.
MY MOM WOULD SAY, WASH HIS MOUTH
OUT WITH SOAP.
HE'S NOT A BAD MAN